que rodrigo arenas vice président de la
fédération du conseil des parents
d'élèves
bonjour rodrigo arenas merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors
vous avez reçu un signalement une
semaine avant la tête d'un parent
d'élève très énervé suite à la diffusion
en classe d'une caricature de mahomet
qui vous a alerté et qu'avez-vous fait
suite à ce signal alors ce sont
évidemment des parents d'élèves qui nous
font remonter ce qu'il voit sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que nous avons des
alertes régulières sur ce type de sujets
comme d'autres d'ailleurs des cas
d'harcèlement d'enfants ou d où des
parents qui veulent simplement se
renseigner sur leurs droits
simplement ce que la presse oublie de
dire dans cet article auquel vous faites
référence c'est que nous avons signalé
cela au maire au maire pourquoi parce
que nous avons estimé que ce qui était
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux étaient
suffisamment probants pour craindre un
trouble à l'ordre public et dans notre
pays
ceux qui sont en charge de l'ordre
public dans une commune ça s'appelle le
maire qui ensuite évidemment travail
avec les services de police pour éviter
les débordements quel qu'il soit c'est
pour cela que j'ai fait prévenir le
maire qui m'a fait appeler dans la
journée pour me dire que toutes les
dispositions ont été prises sur la ville
de conflans sainte honorine
suite à ça à ces messages qui circulait
sur les réseaux sociaux et que
l'éducation nationale parfaitement au
fait de de cette situation mettez tout à
disposition toutes les procédures
normales
en tout cas pas les procédures qui
existent pour ce type de cas dans
l'établissement en lien avec les parents
les enseignants les élèves et tout ce
qui concerne la communauté éducative
alors on imagine bien sûr l'inquiétude
en ce moment des parents des parents
d'élèves
que peuvent faire la fcpe concrètement
pour port tentait de les rassurer
écoutez déjà ce que nous faisons au
quotidien c'est à dire de rappeler le
droit des parents le droit des parents
ce n'est pas faire tout ce qu'on veut
par exemple si ce parents l'avaient été
à la fcpe ils auraient su qu'ils
n'avaient aucun droit à pouvoir juger ou
ou à pouvoir donner son avis ne serait
ce que sur le contenu pédagogique de
l'enseignant dans le cadre de sa classe
la seule chose à laquelle il est
autorisé
c'est de prendre attache avec la chef
d'établissement pour qu'on lui explique
pourquoi et comment est-ce que ce cours
a lieu et on lui aurait expliqué que cet
enseignant était dans son droit et il
n'a pas le droit
comme aucun parent comme aucun citoyen
d'ailleurs de pouvoir être au dessus des
lois et au dessus du droit
c'est cela que nous lui aurions dit
c'est cela qui l'aurait su s'il avait
été adhérent de notre fédération
ce qui n'est pas le cas maintenant qu'à
nous faire en accord évidemment avec les
autorités nous allons travailler d'ores
et déjà un livret de laïcité qui soit
accessible pour les parents parce que
évidemment c'est l'une les censé ignorer
la loi encore faut-il la connaître et
force est de constater que beaucoup de
parents nous disent que si la charte de
la laïcité est une bonne chose
elle est parfois inaccessibles en termes
de contenu en terme de mots qui sont
écrits à l'intérieur et qu'elle demande
un effort d'explication à d'abord un
effort d'éducation et vous savez les
parents aussi ont besoin de cela moi par
exemple j'ai 46 ans je n'ai jamais eu de
cours sur la liberté d'expression
eh ben il est temps que ça change il est
temps que les parents comme moi qui ont
46 ans et qui part pour autant remettre
en question la liberté d'expression
remettent en question le droit au
blasphème remettent en question la
laïcité une sache que la loi est claire
et quand cela il n'appartient à personne
de l'enfreindre donc nous allons mettre
à disposition des documents cas sur
lesquels nous sommes déjà en train de
travailler pour que les parents ne
puisse plus dire nous ne savions pas
parce que nul n'est censé ignorer la loi
et nous allons faire l'effort de la
faire connaître au plus grand nombre de
parents pour qu'ils restent à leur place
est tout à leur place gérald darmanin
veut renforcer la sécurité dans les
établissements scolaires à la rentrée
une bonne idée selon vous il faudrait
pas laisser croire non plus que les
établissements sont des moulins à vent
là où tout est permis vous savez il ya
beaucoup d'établissements en ce moment
qui font l'objet de deux forces
on va dire répressive devant devant les
portes
certains d'ailleurs sont mis en place
par la région et s'interrogent
d'ailleurs s'interroge d'ailleurs sur
l'équipement qui l'on est ce que la
question se pose aujourd'hui est ce que
des des équipes mobiles de sécurité par
exemple qui sont fournies par la région
ile de france équipée de tonfa sont la
meilleure réponse pour des élèves qui
vont dans un lieu qui est un des lieux
scolaires
en revanche ce qui est sûr là où nous
rejoindront les ministres de l'intérieur
si c'est la proposition que je ferai
c'est que les services de police et les
services de renseignement soit équipé de
façon sérieuse pour pouvoir compte
revenir au terrorisme vous savez lutter
contre le terrorisme ce n'est pas une
affaire de parents de je parle dans
l'acteur répressif évidemment et de lacs
de renseignement c'est une affaire d'une
miss à l'intérieur et il sait compter
sur les parents d'élèves de
elle sait que pour faire tout tout
soutien en fait dès lors que nous
pensons qu'une ligne rouge est franchie
et en l'occurrence dans le cas présent
nous avons fait puisque nous avons
alerté le maire qui je les imagine
puisque la police étaient présentes
devant l'établissement depuis une
semaine il a fait son travail d'alerter
les forces de l'ordre
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on pourrait aussi
permettre aux professeurs d'avoir les
moyens de mieux lutter contre ce genre
de chose de mieux lutter contre
l'obscurantisme j'ai envie de dire ah
bah c'est sûr que les enseignants
doivent est épaulé au maximum et pour
cela nous parions aussi sur les parents
vous savez je prends un cas très simple
moi je suis parent d'élève en seine
saint denis quand des enseignants
doivent par exemple organisé un voyage
pour lutter contre l'antisémitisme c'est
à dire aborder les programmes sur le low
cost zinc guerre mondiale nous
accompagnons les parents les enseignants
pour aller à drancy par exemple sur le
surface dans la cité de la muette
nous organisons parfois ddd collecte de
fonds pour que tous les enfants puissent
aller voir les les concentrations est ce
que ça signifie dire que les parents
sont des alliés objectifs des
enseignants évidemment en restant à leur
place c'est à dire que les parents n'ont
pas leur prosélytisme
ils n'ont pas le droit de faire état de
leur religion ils n'ont pas droit de
faire état de leurs opinions politiques
et ils n'ont pas le droit aussi d'aider
des agents commerciaux d'une certaine
façon quand on fait de la pub pour une
marque ch'tis est interdit par la loi
vous voyez ce sont des choses qui
paraissent évidentes mais qui
nécessitent d'être répéter répéter et
encore parce que la laïcité
les valeurs de la république c'est le
rocher de sisyphe on n'en fait jamais
assez donc oui il faut épauler les
enseignants il faut les accompagner
et il faut surtout répondre à parfois
sérieuses et ceux qui se sentent en
solitude face à une classe ou qui ne se
sentent pas suffisamment à l'aise pour
aborder certains sujets les questions de
sexualité par exemple qui sont un vrai
sujet de répondre à ses parents qui font
des nous savons défaut des faux
certificat médical pour empêcher leur
fille d'aller à la piscine parce qu'il
considère que c'est une atteinte à la
pudeur tout ça est illégal tout ça n'est
pas dans le droit
les parents n'ont pas le droit de faire
cela et il faut le rappeler il faut le
marteler parce que nous avons que
l'école pour lutter contre
l'obscurantisme et nous n'avons que
l'école pour lutter contre le dogmatisme
de façon systémique parce qu'en france
nous avons cette chance extraordinaire
c'est qu'un enfant à l'obligation
d'aller à l'école jusqu'à l'âge de 16
ans et cela doit être une force et non
pas un obstacle
et ne doit pas être un problème au
contraire donc soyons au côté les
enseignants notre fédération est à leurs
côtés
et rappelons aux parents qu'ils ne sont
pas là pour contrôler l'école ils sont
là pour avoir le rôle de co éducation
met à leur place de parents et non pas
la place d'enseignants si jamais ils
veulent donner des leçons aux
enseignants je les invite à passer le
concours de la fonction publique pour le
devenir
s'ils veulent si les estiment que la loi
n'est pas respectée je les invite à
passer les concours pour devenir
policier et s'ils pensent que la loi est
enfreinte je les invite à passer le
barreau et devenir avocat parce que tout
ça c'est un métier et parents d'élèves
c'est un métier aussi d'éduquer les
enfants mais en restant à la place de
parents et ne pas confondre le rôle qui
est le leur si beaucoup rodrigo arenas
d'avoir été avec nous cet après midi sur
rt frange rappelle que vous êtes vice
président de la fcpe merci beaucoup